foreign
life without highways
it's not hard to imagine then that the
Advent of Highways changed the face of
the United States forever
people became increasingly connected to
economic opportunities
had easier Access to Health Care and
were more connected to friends and
family across distances than ever
however the Advent of Highways came with
it unintended negative consequences
more cars on the road led to Runaway
pollution
efficient public transportation was
neglected
and some city planners even built
highways to intentionally segregate
cities
now I'm not here to talk to you about
highways but I bring them up because
they are a great way to get you thinking
about three key points about
infrastructure first you take it for
granted second it lasts a long time and
third it has both positive and negative
consequences the impact of which cannot
be predicted at the time of its creation
nowadays there is an invisible
infrastructure system that is
increasingly coming to govern economic
life in the U.S
it has its roots in the 20th century and
has seen a recent wave of exponential
growth over the last few years
much like physical infrastructure its
effects extend to economic life
social and Leisure Time as well as
health outcomes
this invisible infrastructure system
that I'm talking to you about is data
infrastructure now before I talk to you
concretely about what data
infrastructure is and what you should
think about it I want to get a little
audience participation to get you
thinking about it intuitively
raise your hand if the following applies
how many of you
over the last year have woken up gone to
turn on the faucet to brush your teeth
and wondered where did that water
actually come from
some hands but not that many now how
many of you over the past year have been
browsing the internet
seen an oddly specific ad and thought
where did that come from how did they
know
lots more hands
over 2000 years ago the Romans built the
aqueducts and now we take running water
for granted similarly over the last
hundred years highways have been built
and now we always take for granted that
we can get from point A to point B no
matter the distance
much like the Unstoppable tide of
Transportation infrastructure or
Plumbing data infrastructure is
increasingly a part of everyday life the
only difference is that it is invisible
and you have no idea how or why this is
happening the best you have is wondering
about that eerily well-placed ad
so as promised what is data
infrastructure data infrastructure is
software but it is also infrastructure
like roads or utilities
it is invisible which is why you
probably haven't thought about it before
up until now
data itself comes from many different
places such as credit card transactions
security cameras at the airport sensor
data is on an ATM or clicks and movement
of your mouse online
data infrastructure is the most
fundamental infrastructure before we can
make meaning out of this data it is the
pipes boxes and machines that do things
to data
like move it store it and structure it
so that we can use it it is akin to oil
refineries and pipelines without which
we would have no use for crude oil
data infrastructure is how data freely
flows from creation to usage
the business processes enabled by data
infrastructure are increasingly
prevalent because they have become
possible through advances in
infrastructure technology
we can process data to make jobs
redundant we can process data to create
systems for early disease detection we
can process data to make machines that
can fix themselves by taking in data
about themselves
I first became interested in data
infrastructure while working in
technology private Equity investing in
high growth data analytics businesses in
my free time I was reading books about
U.S infrastructure and I couldn't help
but notice the parallels between the
roads and utilities and bridges of the
physical world and the very same of the
digital world
this was a thread that I had to keep
pulling because it touched on so many
areas that were interesting to me
human technology interactions public
policy hard science
I'm fascinated by the technology but
more than anything I am both excited and
cautious about the future of data
infrastructure I'm excited because
there's so much this technology can do
to make life better that we should
nurture we can process data from blood
tests to detect cancer without invasive
procedures
we can process camera data so that our
cars can drive themselves we can process
sensor data to reduce bias in law
enforcement and criminal justice and we
can process satellite images to identify
poaching hot spots to prevent unwanted
extinctions
however I am cautious because we are in
the early Innings of coming to a mature
data infrastructure ecosystem
in the future organizations will
continue to implement ready
off-the-shelf infrastructure software
like installing a pipe in your home
plumbing system
with this comes the risk of job
displacement of people who previously
did this work manually but it also come
but it also brings the opportunity for
people to focus on more meaningful work
Beyond automation
the business processes the data
infrastructure enables are becoming
increasingly prevalent because the
infrastructure itself is becoming
increasingly prevalent
organizations are becoming increasingly
masterful at keeping your eyeballs on
their social network or their infinite
feed of videos that you scroll for hours
before bed
organizations are becoming increasingly
masterful at using recommendation
engines to help you open up your wallet
and make one additional purchase
in short organizations are becoming
increasingly extractive of people in
society because they are able to better
collect data analyze it more efficiently
analyze it faster and do more with it
now than ever
what will the world look like when this
technology is truly pervasive
there are no easy answers to questions
like these but for three reasons I want
to convince you that you are the perfect
person to answer them
data infrastructure is poorly understood
by Regulators it is poorly understood by
the public it is increasingly becoming
part of business everywhere
first the regulatory framework for data
infrastructure is limited there is some
legislation that tells you what data you
can collect but by and large it doesn't
say much about what you can do with that
data once it is collected it is like
telling a water Bottling Company where
they can get their water but not what
they have to do to it before they serve
it to you second popular understanding
is fairly poor this is fair because the
technology is complex and oftentimes
very new and so decision making in this
realm has up until now been mostly
concentrated within the highly technical
technical people of the world such as
phds who created the technology
and third
great data infrastructure in the
business processes it enables are no
longer reserved for large tech companies
with big pools of technical Talent
entrepreneurs are increasingly bringing
these Technologies to Market and
spreading them throughout the corporate
world
so why am I telling you that the
regulatory framework is limited that
popular understanding is poor and that
this stuff is everywhere it's to
convince you that the current system
doesn't have all the answers and your
voice can make an impact
Business Leaders of the world will be
forced to make relevant choices as every
organization becomes a data driven
organization it is akin to voting if you
do not educate yourself and make your
voice heard you will not have an impact
in shaping the future
that is why it is imperative
that you do not let or you do not leave
the understanding to someone else
read Tech journalism
pay attention the next time there's a
technology related Congressional hearing
talk about your ideas with friends and
family
bring this conversation to everyone
because this is a topic that affects
everyone
all of this said differently the world
is changing in invisible ways
the invisible roads are being built and
the invisible pipes are being laid
what are the consequences of the public
or the government are left out of the
design choices as this invisible system
is being built
be excited about
what this new technology can bring
and all of the improvements to life
that it can be that can come with it
but never stop paying attention to it
because we do not know yet what the
world will look like when this
technology is truly mature and pervasive
unlike physical infrastructure data
infrastructure is easy to forget because
it is 99 invisible don't let it be out
of sight out of mind
thank you
[Music]